waiting for more John Wick missing the
Marvel universe or maybe you're after
something new the writers and actors
strike may have cast some of these
release dates in doubt but 2024 is still
looking like a heck of a year for film
Sony's Spider-Man universe is ready to
reopen in 2024 with the release of the
weirder Wilder and woman-centric
spin-off Madam Webb based on a somewhat
obscure Marvel Comics character the film
will introduce audiences to Mystical
Oracle Cassandra Webb an elderly Ally of
the webbed wall crawler who uses her
powers of Clairvoyance to see into his
future with her unique and surprising
psychic powers Webb isn't the kind of
action-oriented hero you might expect to
see carry their own big budget feature
film to that end it seems that Sony has
made some significant changes to the
character for the upcoming movie
including casting a young actor Dakota
Johnson in the title role Madam Webb
will be joined by quite a talented cast
featuring Stars such as Sydney Sweeney
Celeste O'Connor and Adam Scott Sweeney
was recently confirmed to be playing
Julia Carpenter an early iteration of
Spider-Woman in the characters
live-action debut indeed the film is
expected to see a team up of various
spider women drawn from the comics
though little is known about the plot at
this stage Sony will no doubt be hoping
for another success like Tom Hardy's
Venom when Madam Webb lands in theaters
it's currently still slated for release
on February 16 2024 though we'll have to
see if the film actually hits that
release date either way the worst case
scenario for the movie we'd imagine
looks a little something like this
intriguing it's no easy task to go even
bigger than the Blockbuster crossover
Godzilla vs Kong but the sequel Godzilla
x-con the new Empire is going to give it
a shot the previous film faced a mighty
challenge back in 2021 as it released to
theaters and on HBO Max simultaneously
due to the ongoing covid-19 pandemic
nevertheless it managed to net an
impressive 470 million dollars with
theaters once again a big attraction
these days the sequel stands to fare
much better Godzilla X Kong the new
Empire will see The Return of Rebecca
Hall as Dr Eileen Andrews and Brian
Tyree Henry as Bernie Hayes while Legion
star Dan Stevens joins the franchise in
an as yet undisclosed role but while the
first film depicted the epic battle
between the two Titanic Terrors the new
Empire will flip the script picking up
where the last film left off Kong and
Godzilla are now reluctant to allies and
the sequel will see the two beasts team
up to take on a new Menace the new
Empire is set to be released on March
15th 2024
Disney's live-action remakes have been
hit or missed to say the least but that
hasn't slowed the studio down one bit in
2024 they're going to tackle a classic
releasing a live-action version of Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs one of the
most beloved animated films of all time
if Disney is going to do it justice
they'll need a roster of the industry's
best talent to bring it to Life Academy
Award nominee Greta Gerwig has been
hired to pen the script while the
Amazing Spider-Man's Mark Webb is set to
direct Rachel zegler of West Side Story
Fame takes on the title role while Gal
Gadot trades in her own heroic Tiara for
a crown to play the evil queen Disney
has truncated the movie's title to the
simpler Snow White and they're also
planning to update the classic story for
modern audiences the essence Remains the
Same however like the original Snow
White will follow a young princess who
is pursued by a vile Queen and aided by
seven hospitable dwarves will snow white
be able to recapture the magic and meet
with a claim like John favreau's The
Jungle Book or will it land with a sud
like pretty much all of the others we'll
find out when the film arrives on March
22nd 2024
after Ryan Reynolds all but forced Fox
to push the start button on the Deadpool
franchise The Merc with the mouth turned
out two massive money-making hits but
questions immediately arose when the
studio was gobbled up by Disney would
Marvel want the foul-mouthed R-rated
Deadpool films integrated into their
family-friendly MCU those concerns were
put to bed in early 2021 by Marvel's
head honcho Kevin feige who declared
that there would indeed be a third
Deadpool movie and that it would retain
its harsh rating glorious violence and
dark sense of humor but fans were in for
one more surprise when the film was
officially announced the following year
Reynolds revealed that Hugh Jackman
would be joining him for the threequel
reprising his role as Wolverine a return
he'd previously sworn off we don't know
much about the plot of Deadpool 3
although it's likely the film will
depict an epic Clash and eventual team
up between Wade Wilson and Logan Adam
Project's Sean Levy will be directing
and a number of cast members from
Deadpool and Deadpool 2 will return too
including
Brianna Hildebrand and even Rob Delaney
never underestimate a man with a
mustache just ask anyone in Brooklyn
you're a goddamn superhero you that's
four
the cast also includes Emma coren and
Matthew McFadden in unannounced roles
Deadpool 3 is planned to hit theaters on
May 3rd 2024 though production is
currently stopped due to the writers and
actors strike
John Wick is one of the modern day's
hottest movie series and in 2024 the
franchise brings us the second of two
upcoming spin-off projects ballerina set
between the third and fourth John Wick
films ballerina Stars Anna De armas as a
Deadly Assassin with Keanu Reeves due to
return in an extended cameo role other
actors scheduled to return in some
capacity or another include Angelica
Houston as the Director Ian McShane as
Winston and Lance Reddick as Sharon in
one of the late star's final
performances Len Wiseman who held the
2012 remake of Total Recall is taking
directorial duties on ballerina while
Emerald fennel writer director of
promising young woman joined Shea Hatton
to work on the script though not much
has been released regarding the film's
story ballerina stands to be another
first-rate action thriller and if the
John Wick films are anything to go by
it'll no doubt blow fans away when it
releases the film is slated to arrive on
June 7 2024.
Pixar is known for founding wildly
popular franchises such as Toy Story and
cars and in 2024 they'll add another to
its ranks with inside out too the first
film in the series came out all the way
back in 2015 and while the kids who saw
it in theaters may have grown up the
sequel stands to bring in a whole new
generation of viewers written and
directed by Pixar veteran Pete doctor
the first Inside Out centers around a
young girl named Riley whose emotions
manifest as characters inside her head
the movie was a monster hit amassing
more than 800 million dollars at the box
office thus far Amy Poehler is the only
cast member officially announced for the
sequel she'll reprise the role of Joy
actor Mindy Kaling who voiced disgust
has revealed that she is not involved
with rumors swirling about contract
negotiations breaking down over a salary
dispute Bill Hader who played fear will
not be coming back either but Lewis
Black and Phyllis Smith who play anger
and sadness respectively are expected to
return as for the plot well polar has
revealed that the film will pick up with
Riley as she deals with the emotional
changes of adolescence hey guys what's
puberty I don't know it's probably not
important but we'll have to wait for
June 14 2024 to see how it all goes down
Disney's live-action Lion King movie
proved divisive among fans and critics
with many feeling the shot for shot
remake was a wholly unnecessary Endeavor
but the box office doesn't lie The Lion
King made over one billion dollars in
theaters making it quite clear there's a
huge appetite for more Adventures at
Pride Rock thus in 2024 Disney will
release a prequel Mufasa The Lion King
if Beale Street could talk director
Barry Jenkins replaces John Favreau
behind the camera while Aaron Pierre
will step in as the voice of a younger
Mufasa returning cast members for the
prequel include Billy Eichner and Seth
Rogen as Timon and Pumbaa as well as
John Connie as Rafiki Calvin Harrison Jr
will voice the younger scar once again
Disney will use lifelike CGI animation
to recreate these stunning
photorealistic world of The Lion King
this time for a story that explores
Mufasa's youth Disney has so far
revealed that a devastating flood leaves
him orphaned to be adopted by another
Pride battling against the odds this
ordinary Outsider will rise up to take
his place as the king of the jungle and
it's planned to happen on July 5th 2024.
the second animated sequel to drop in
the summer of 2024 Despicable Me 4 comes
seven years after the third installment
but just two years after the third
minion spin-off film which told the
origin of the film's anti-hero grew in
this installment Gru is back once again
voiced by Steve Carell while Kristen
Wiig returns as Lucy Gru's wife and an
agent of the anti-villain league the
little yellow minion zoo or at least
your kids love will be back too played
by voice actor Pierre coffin what will
they be up to well the details are
sketchy at this point but what we do
know is that the fourth film will begin
shortly after the events of Despicable
Me 3 and will follow Gru his family and
his minions as they hunt bad guys for
the anti-villain league so far
illumination has kept quiet regarding
the plot's exact details which we
probably won't learn more about before
the first trailer releases but there may
be a wait for the first footage as the
film's ultimate release is still fairly
far away Despicable Me 4 is scheduled
for July 3rd 2024.
based on the novel by am Shine the
Watchers is a supernatural Thriller
whose director is Shauna Shyamalan has
been making a few waves recently the
daughter of legendary director M Night
Shyamalan Ashana cut her teeth as second
unit director on her father's movie old
she also worked as a producer writer and
director on the Apple TV series servant
the Watchers will be her big screen
debut when it premieres in 2024. the
novel tells the story of mina a woman
who becomes lost in an Irish forest and
struggles to survive while being hunted
by strange otherworldly monsters in this
film version of the story actress Dakota
Fanning will star as Mina while Georgina
Campbell has been cast in a leading role
alongside her adapted to film by Ashana
Shyamalan and am Shine the script became
the subject of a minor bidding war among
rival studios in the end new line Cinema
won out though not yet in production the
Watchers is due to begin filming in Fall
2023 with a planned release date of June
7th 2024.
M Night Shyamalan films are fairly
divisive but the director's willingness
to take big swings on unique projects
always makes them must-watch experiences
that's especially true now that he's
focused himself on making smaller
stranger titles such as the visit and
old whether you loved these movies or
hated them they certainly got people
talking that's what makes Shyamalan
special he's always bringing something
fresh to a cinematic landscape dominated
by familiar brand names and he's not
done yet in 2023 Shyamalan faced the
apocalypse with knock at the cabin and
in 2024 he'll be leading us straight
into trap which is set for release on
August 2nd 2024. other than that we
don't know much about it will it be an
original Shyamalan script will it be
adapted from a previous work will it
feature any big names that the director
worked with before we're not sure the
only other bit of info we know at the
moment is that trap will be the first
film in a multi-year first look deal
Shyamalan signed with Warner Brothers
meaning the director is finally leaving
Universal his long time Studio home
if you're looking for a studio with a
consistent track record of first-rate
horror movies and thrillers it's hard to
find better than blumhouse since 2010
they've been responsible for some of the
most popular and critically acclaimed
horror films around they've also been a
showcase for up-and-coming directors
courtesy of hits such as James wands
Insidious Jordan peels get out and Lee
winnell's The Invisible Man
usually teach you something so naturally
the Studio's upcoming suspense story
speak no evil is also bound to be a hit
a remake of a 2022 Danish film of the
same name speak no evil is helmed by a
woman and black director James Watkins
and will star James McAvoy whose
performance in Blum House is split and
glass earned him critical Acclaim the
Danish original follows Bjorn and Louise
a couple who are invited to spend a
holiday with Patrick Karen and their son
Abel after meeting them on vacation in
Tuscany planned as a pleasant weekend in
a remote Village in the Netherlands
Bjorn and Louise's getaway spirals out
of control when their hosts begin
exhibiting Disturbing Behavior McAvoy
will feature in the film alongside scoop
McNary and Mackenzie Davis of Terminator
dark fate Fame the film is currently
scheduled to hit theaters on August 9
2024.
there are few films more iconic to The
Goth crowd than Beetlejuice the 1988
absurdist black comedy from director Tim
Burton the film starred Winona Ryder as
Lydia Dietz a morose teen who moves into
a new home and meets the ghosts of
married couple Barbara and Adam as well
as a SAS talking trickster from the
underworld named Beetlejuice strange
surreal and entirely One of a Kind the
film made Tim Burton one of Hollywood's
hottest directors and helps solidify
both writer and Michael Keaton as stars
and while all attempts to get a sequel
off the ground have failed thus far it
looks like we're finally getting one in
2024 announced in May 2023 Beetlejuice 2
is finally a go and it already has its
Leading Lady attached Jenna Ortega who
more than proved her goth credentials in
Netflix's Wednesday it looks like Winona
Ryder is coming back as Lydia Dietz too
presumably the mother of Ortega's new
character she'll be joined by Catherine
O'Hara as Delia Deets and Monica
Bellucci as beetlejuice's wife Justin
Thoreau will play an unknown part and
Screen Legend Willem Dafoe appears to be
playing some sort of afterlife law
enforcement officer and of course you
can't make a Beetlejuice movie without
Michael Keaton luckily the
oscar-nominated star is indeed returning
as the Ghost with the most it's showtime
Wednesday scribes Miles Miller and
Alfred go are writing the script while
Burton himself is expected to direct
Beetlejuice 2 is expected to arrive in
theaters on September 24th 2024.
despite suffering a steady decline in
box office takings Paramount continues
to forge ahead with the Transformers
movie franchise hot on the heels of
Transformers rise of the beasts the
studio is set to return the series to
its animated Roots Transformers 1 a
fully animated feature film explores the
origins of the Autobots and Decepticons
on Cybertron long before the events of
the 2007 Blockbuster series revolving
around the unlikely friendship between
Optimus Prime and Megatron this movie
will Chronicle their journey to becoming
bitter Rivals and deadly enemies the
voice cast is impressive with a group of
A-list Superstars lending their talents
to the cartoon prequel including Chris
Hemsworth and Brian Tyree Henry Toy
Story 4 filmmaker Josh Cooley directs
the movie while Steven Spielberg once
again serves as producer Transformers
fans can expect to see the movie roll
out in cinemas on September 13 2024.
many fans believe that the third
installment in a superhero Trilogy tends
to be the worst it certainly Rings true
for the X-Men Trilogy Sam raimi's
Spider-Man movies and Blade Trinity
although recent threequels such as
Captain America Civil War and Spider-Man
no way home appear to have broken the
curse in 2024 Sony is hoping to continue
that positive trend with a third Venom
film currently scheduled for July 2024
and a rare move of the studios
announcing a sooner release date than
the original announcement for October
2024. Tom Hardy will be back in the
title role of course while Dr Strange's
chuatel edgio 4 has been cast in an
undisclosed part and Emmy nominated Ted
lasso star Juno Temple has joined the
cast as well and while Andy Circus
impressed behind the director's chair in
the second film screenwriter Kelly
Marcel will take the helm for this one
Marcel who wrote the first two movies is
also pinning the script based on a story
she developed with Hardy little is known
about the plot of the third movie but
after the conclusion of the previous
film there are plenty of dangling plot
threads to follow that said given Tom
Holland's recent announcement that he's
about to take a break from acting it's
unlikely we'll see his Peter Parker
taking on Eddie Brock just yet despite
the tease in Let There Be Carnage still
considering the billion dollar gross of
the first two films and overwhelmingly
positive reviews from fans expectations
are high for the next movie to deliver
even more spine tingling Thrills
over-the-top spills and gut-busting
kills only time will tell whether the
threequel curse is truly broken
it's rare to see a sequel to a best
picture Oscar winner let alone a legacy
sequel decades later but that's exactly
what we're getting in 2024 when Ridley
Scott returns to direct Gladiator 2. the
original released in 2001 five Academy
Awards quickly cementing its reputation
as a bona fide classic the third classic
movie to which Scott has returned in
recent years Gladiator 2 will see a
mostly new cast of characters populate a
story that takes place in a very
different world
[Music]
[Applause]
Paul Mezcal who earned an Oscar
nomination for his work in after sun
stars as the lead character a grown-up
Lucius the young boy portrayed by
Spencer Treat Clark in the original film
Connie Nielsen will be returning as
lucius's mother Lucilla daughter of the
late Emperor Marcus Aurelius they will
be joined by an All-Star cast that
includes May kalamawi Denzel Washington
Pedro Pascal Barry Keogan and Derek
Jacoby meanwhile David Scarpa has penned
the script Gladiator 2 is scheduled for
November 22nd 2024.
after years of stop starts and missed
release dates a feature film adaptation
of wicked is finally on the way this
vision of L frank bombs Oz reimagines
Elphaba the Wicked Witch of the West as
a sympathetic protagonist her story is
told through an array of vibrant musical
numbers that have become enormously
popular with theater kids and audiences
alike given that ubiquity it's no
surprise that the general public are so
hotly anticipating a movie version of
Wicked This adaptation is directed by
John M Chu who proved his musical chops
helming the in the Heights movie while
Cynthia arrivo of Harriet and pop star
Ariana Grande headline a star-studded
ensemble cast as Elphaba and Glinda
respectively they'll be joined here by
the oscar-winning Michelle yo as
madamorable and Jeff Goldblum as The
Wizard of Oz with a lead cast like that
there's no question that the Beloved
musical numbers in Wicked will be
delivered with plenty of Gusto and
energy fans can get excited about the
potential for memorable imagery and
choose vibrant visual sensibilities too
it's take in countless years of nervous
anticipation but the first installment
in the two-part Wicked movie series is
finally going to arrive in theaters on
November 27 2024.
all right Eggman you want to get fast
let's get fast
video game adaptations used to be known
as a dud genre thanks to no small part
to Sonic the Hedgehog however they are
now hotter than ever one of the last
Blockbusters to release before the
covid-19 pandemic struck in 2020 the
first Sonic film took in 319 million
dollars at the global box office its
sequel performed even better Sonic the
Hedgehog 2 introduced the villain
Knuckles voiced by Idris Elba who is due
for his own spin-off TV series on
Paramount plus and the movie franchise
isn't slowing down anytime soon as a
proper three-qual Sonic the Hedgehog 3
will drop in 2024. not much is known
about this next entry in the series
right now however a tease on Twitter
announcing the film back in August 2022
suggests that both Tails and Knuckles
could be back in Action alongside the
eponymous Sonic once again voiced by Ben
Schwartz nobody's too sure whether Jim
Carrey will return as Dr Robotnik
however as the actor has said that he is
curious about retiring from acting if he
stands by his word will be in for a new
villain because producers have said they
have no plans to replace Carrie in the
role either way Sonic is speeding
towards release on December 20th 2024.
first introduced in the comics is a
morally ambiguous replacement for The
Avengers the Thunderbolts team is
composed of a variety of former villains
the MCU movie Thunderbolts however will
introduce a slightly different team
announced in 2022 Thunderbolts will act
as a culmination of multiple storylines
from previous films featuring a cast
made up of previously seen anti-heroes
this includes Red Guardian Elena Bulova
Taskmaster the Winter Soldier U.S agent
and the Mysterious ghost it still fits
they'll be led by CIA director Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine although it remains
to be seen if Harrison Ford's Thaddeus
Ross will be a member of the team we
know Ford will be showing up in Captain
America Brave New World but there's been
no confirmation that this character will
appear in the film just yet meanwhile
Walking Dead star Stephen Yoon has
joined the cast too with all signs
suggesting that he will be playing these
super-powered Goliath known as the
Sentry directed by Jake schreier and
penned by Lee seung-jin both of whom
recently struck gold with the Netflix
series beef the film seems poised to
rock the very foundations of the MCU
expect to see these ragtag heroes in
action on December 20th 2024.
once known only as a comedian Jordan
peel has recently established himself as
one of the brightest writer directors in
Hollywood oozing with atmosphere and
filled with symbolism and allegory his
2017 sci-fi thriller get out blew the
world away with its story of a young man
who discovers a terrifying and bizarre
secret after meeting his girlfriend's
family often exploring themes of racism
and social injustice peels films have
garnered an outpouring of critical
Acclaim with follow-ups us and nope
delivering plenty of Thrills and
thought-provoking Dramatics in 2023 it
was announced that peels as yet Untitled
fourth film will arrive on Christmas Day
2024 making it alternative programming
for big budget Blockbusters Sonic the
Hedgehog 3 and Thunderbolts as of press
time we don't know the genre of the film
let alone who will star or what it will
be about will it be a chilling horror
movie like us or a mind-bending Sci-Fi
like get out nobody knows but one thing
is for sure this movie will no doubt be
a highly inventive project starring some
of the best actors in Hollywood after
all peel remains one of the most
in-demand filmmakers currently working
while we can't say who's involved just
yet you can make a safe bet that Daniel
kaluya will likely make an appearance as
the British actor has starred in two of
Peel's three films so far
actor turned director John Krasinski is
still wowing audiences in front of the
camera with his leading role in the
fourth and final season of Jack Ryan
after that though he'll be turning his
attention back to directing in fact he
recently announced his next film and
it's not what you might expect from the
creator of a quiet place Krasinski is
mostly keeping tight-lipped about the
project for now but the name of the film
is intriguing enough on its own it's
titled simply if if is said to be a
story about childhood imagination during
a presentation of behind the scenes
footage at cinemacon Krasinski said I
had this idea for a movie years ago
about imaginary friends the film's cast
will be a mix of live-action stars and
voice Talent featuring Krasinski himself
and a number of Hollywood heavyweights
from Ryan Reynolds to Emily Blunt to
Matt Damon and more despite all that
secrecy if has already completed filming
the movie is due for release on May 24
2024.
no